Amy Klobuchar who of course was running
for president as a Democrat a couple
years ago she's largely become
irrelevant but she's still she's still
hanging around she was on Meet the Press
with Chuck Todd now Chuck Todd is
obviously a Democrat he is a Democrat
activist pretending to be a journalist
and here they are talking about
censorship and big Tech and what we
should do about all of you people who
say things that they don't like would it
look let's be realistic the the tobacco
companies changed after being hit with
Hefty lawsuits more than government
regulation after the lawsuits came more
government regulation do you think if
you open these company up companies up
to lawsuits and by the way Facebook's
being sued overseas for what it what its
role in um in an Ethiopian Civil War and
some other places
um do you think their behavior would
change yes because then in order to
continue they have to put safety
measures in place instead of sending out
sweet little notes about all the good
work they're doing they would actually
have to do something
how these guys actually act in cahoots
the way he frames the question comparing
big tech companies who don't do what he
wants which is silence you to Tobacco
companies that's the danger now tobacco
companies knowingly were killing people
everyone knew that nicotine was
addictive they knew that they were
putting all sorts of other chemicals in
there and they knew how many people were
dying of emphysema or lung cancer etc
etc and they had all this junk science
and all these people that they would put
on these shows to lie about it and
everything else comparing that to Big
tech companies and I'm not defending big
tech companies but their their argument
is Big tech companies are not doing
enough to silence you this is it's such
a crazy jump in logic but he frames it
that way and that's just perfect for her
to say ah if they don't do what we want
then we're going to start suing them
into Oblivion or we'll break them up or
we'll send Regulators in there or God
knows what so you have a giant news
organization NBC News calling for the
Silence of people and why would they do
that because they want them properly on
information right Chuck Todd does not
want I don't know Chuck Todd but Chuck
Todd does not want you watching the
Reuben report right Chuck Dodd doesn't
want you thinking about things that are
outside of the window of the things that
he wants you to think about right of
course not of course not right he wants
people to to believe in his worldview
and watch that I would like if more
people believed in my world view but I'm
not out there trying to censor other
people and of course the really
interesting part about that is what they
keep telling you they're worried about
is misinformation and disinformation but
if we were to go through the Litany of
things that Chuck Todd and NBC News at
CNN in Washington posted everywhere else
has lied about over the last couple
years they would all be banning
themselves and suing themselves into
Oblivion and much more foreign